trois jours que la tornade a traversé la
communauté de mai field raflant tout sur
son passage
près de l'église baptiste complètement
dévasté des bénévoles distribuent de la
nourriture déshabille et surtout de lots
de ces steaks
c'est bouleversant dit elle j'ai appelé
ma mère et j'ai pleuré quand je suis
arrivé ici mais qui nofit le responsable
fait le tour des maisons native de mes
filles il n'arrive pas à croire que
cette ville jadis si vivante soit
anéantie existe un mécanisme en deçà il
s'est vraiment dérangeant utile car
c'est ma ville et maintenant il n'ya pas
plus tôt dans la journée le gouverneur
de l'état indique monsieur elle
n'arrivait pas non plus à contenir sa
peine
parmi les morts 18 n'ont toujours pas
été identifiés le tube l'âge varie de
cinq mois à 86 ans et six avaient moins
de 18 ans sans abri depuis trois jours
jennifer et son fils chéri viennent
récupérer leurs biens leur maison est
devenue inhabitable après 12 ans de vie
traîne ici vivent maintenant dans un
centre commercial en attendant d'être
relogées
il ya eu beaucoup de l'art beaucoup de
larmes dit elle il faut garder un sens
de l'humour on n'a pas le choix
heureusement on a eu le soutien de la
famille et dé m la ville ressemble à une
zone de guerre un peu plus loin la
police militaire interdit l'accès à
l'usiné de bougies qui a été
complètement anéanti au moins huit
personnes ont perdu la vie nous sommes
au centre ville de mes filtres sur le
boulevard commercial juste derrière moi
l'église a été complètement détruite et
tous les commerces sur cette rue ont
totalement été rasé la tornade est passé
vendredi soir et n'a rien laissé sur son
passage
encore aujourd'hui 105 personnes sont
portées disparues le bilan final ne sera
connu que dans quelques semaines sur le
gouverneur mais au beau milieu de ce
paysage apocalyptique des enfants
tentent de réparer leurs trampoline pour
recommencer à jouer un signe que la vie
de finir par reprendre son cours malgré
tout il s'est évadé guergis radio-canada
méfier quant à qui